(keyboard music)
- [Stevo] It's the perfect day.
You know what I'm talking about?
It's the perfect day to just go outside,
and do stuff with your friends.
Or friend.
Your human friend, your animal friend,
doesn't really matter.
Does it?
My friend Shabby,
is an African Sulcata tortoise,
but she's from Southern California,
which is funny.
Sometimes if one of us is feeling blue,
we'll just go to the park,
and we'll hang.
We decided to try yoga for the first time.
So we found some mats, and
we got our downward dog on.
Or, at least tried to.
I mean tried to,
so I don't think Shabby
was feeling it too much.
After working up an appetite,
I got us a croissant from the cafe.
I wasn't too into it though,
and I don't think Shabby was either.
So we went ahead,
and we just fed it to
one of the local ducks.
Between you and me,
I think Shabby has
something against ducks,
but I think they're fine,
so whatever.
Sometimes in friendship,
there's these differences
that you discover about each other.
They could seem a little
bit irreconcilable.
At one point,
Shabby's lack of interest
in some of the things we were doing,
just got me so heated,
that I just split,
and went and chilled with
some of the birds at the park.
Or I tried to.
But none of them seemed to wanna
build a friendship with me.
That's cool.
That's totally fine.
Luckily true friends take you back.
Even after you've thrown a fit.
And it's a good thing,
because when you've had the perfect day,
you know there can be no catch.
There's only love,
and that's more than enough,
I get that I'm not cut out for everyone,
which is probably why my
only friend is a tortoise.
Who can't hear me. (laughing)